every day people the world over use  plastic shopping bags they're  lightweight hard-wearing and often come  for free  but how harmful are plastic bags to the  climate every year more than 600 billion  plastic bags are manufactured worldwide  four percent of the crude oil consumed  globally every year ends up in plastic  bags but is a fossil fuel and supplies  are slowly coming to an end  manufacturing and shipping plastic bags  requires large amounts of energy and  also causes 60 tons of co2 emissions  every year on average plastic bags are  in use for just 25 minutes then they're  thrown away few of them are recycled  most plastic bags end up in rivers on  the streets or in the ocean  some countries have banned plastic bags  entirely while in others it's illegal to  give them away for free